it's now 1 o'clock I'm going to go ahead
and uh open uh today's hearing on uh
division 3 Finance
today's topic is this an informational
meeting um we're going to hear about
Medicaid Medicare choices for
Independence Nursing Facility financing
was scheduled for
today but we're going to slide that part
of it the nursing facility financing to
another day there's a something referred
to often as a county cap and uh we're
going to discuss that separately on a
different day so this won't be a
particularly long hearing I don't think
but I think it's going to be extremely
educational particularly for the new
members of division 3 Medicaid is vital
to the care we provide to our public and
um and understanding the nuances of it
um is important for us so um I have to
apologize for my lack of decorum
thought my jacket and tie were in the
back of my car when I drove off
fortunately I had a a coat so I'm going
to I'm going to go like this and hope
people aren't so offended they change
the channel but um so uh I'll let you
all begin where you want to
begin good afternoon my name is Ann
Landry good afternoon my name is Ann
Landry and I'm ass so ass at
commissioner at the Department of Health
colleagues I'm Jonathan Ballard at work
as the chief medical
officer and good afternoon I'm Henry
director thank you thank you for having
us here today I'm going to kick us off
as I promised last week during the
commissioner's overview of the
department that I would come back with
Henry Litman to give you a deep dive
into the Medicaid Program um and the
differences between Medicaid and
Medicare so today we are going to talk
about again just the Medicaid benefit in
general um the different eligibility
categories the enrollment numbers for
the State of New Hampshire and really
dive into what our coverable services
are here as well as the finance
mechanisms um and the different programs
with which we partner um and we have a
lot to say and also Jonathan will Dr
ball will help cover some of our program
elements as
well if we turn to slide four just a
really high overview and again Henry and
Jonathan will um dive a little bit
deeper into this but Medicaid is a
longstanding public health benefit that
provides care to our state's most
vulnerable um residents whether that's
lwi income or pregnant women and
children or people with disabilities are
different are different
categories um what Henry always likes to
say and what we like to say is that if
you've seen one Medicaid Program you've
seen one Medicaid Program and that
really highlights because although it's
a Fally it's a federal program it's also
State driven so it's a partnership
between the federal um federal
government and the different states with
shared um shared funding and each state
is slightly different in both what we
cover and who is eligible so we'll dive
a a little bit deeper into
that as we turn to slide five this is a
really high level overview of what um of
the New Hampshire Medicaid numbers so we
have the fourth smallest Medicaid
program in the country only one in seven
New Hampshire residents are covered by
Medicaid that's comparable that's
comparable to one in five at the
national level so we have a really small
program that covers about
184,000 um New Hampshire
residents as you turn to uh slide six
this elaborates um oh and I I'm sorry I
was remissed to say if you have
questions along the way we can either do
them at the end of each section or
throughout or whoever whoever serves you
best but feel free to let us know if you
have questions um slide six digs a
little bit deeper into what that
overview is as you can see compared to
um the Nationwide again we have one in
seven New Hampshire citizens whereas the
the country as one in five um and really
what the two primary drivers for this
difference are really the age and income
demographics in our state as far as
who's even eligible for Medicaid um to
begin with so our program is much
smaller and if you turn to page seven a
little bit more you'll see how we
compare to the National averages um so
we have about 65% of adults New
Hampshire on Medicaid are working that's
higher than the national compar
comparison of 61 or
61% we also only have 22% of our births
covered by Medicaid New Hampshire that's
compared to the 42% at the national
level so again much much smaller program
here in New Hampshire and I think what's
most interesting to you on this slide is
if you take a look at um the uninsured
rate for the country for the United
States that's the dotted line at the top
we the dark black line underneath so we
have a much smaller insured rate in the
state of New Hampshire which again
contributes to our lower um Medicaid
numbers with that I'll turn it over to
Henry for a little
bit there's a
question yeah what do we attribute that
do we attribute that
to do we attribute
the yeah do we attribute the differences
to our demographics compared to the rest
of the states or what would you
attribute the the differences what we're
looking at
here so one major difference is New
Hampshire's um per capita income is
higher than many states um in fact I
think we're in the top few um and then
when you look at demographics we're one
of the older uh states in the country
you know I talk about meeting people for
dinner at four o'clock in Florida it's
actually New Hampshire has an average
age higher than um than
there's another question represent
Mooney thank you very much and thank you
all for being here where would one find
which I'm sure as an extensive document
a list of conditions that are covered by
Medicaid including
you so the standard will'll go through
this a slide forward about what is
covered by Medicaid and the criteria of
what is has what components must be met
to be a covered service but one of those
standards is medically necessary and so
we'll talk a little bit about what are
the required conditions and what's as
mandatory from the federal partners for
the states to cover and what is optional
services but for all medical conditions
they are covered if so all outpatient
and hospitalized medical conditions both
physical and psychological when they are
deemed medically necessary by current
standard of practice of published
required
we thank you what is the income limit
below income we have um later in the
deck a slide that shows you at different
family sizes if if you're okay waiting
to get to that but we will address that
that would be great and and then on on
slide seven where you show 65% of adults
in New Hampshire on Medica are working
is that say that they're working but not
not making the threshold cor correct um
and you know the amount of work is not
necessarily defined here it could be 10
hours a week it could be 40 hours a week
um but you know if you're basically
earning more than $8 an hour um as an
individual for example you'd be over the
threshold for a single person um on
granted Advantage as an example but
we'll get into that a little further if
you okay so I'm going to run by slide
eight other than saying Medicaid and
Medicare are not the
same um and jump to slide
nine so can I ask you a question here
sure okay I get it these are different
but do we also have to contend with
federal grants is that another major
source of of federal funding we actually
address that later on too but to give
you a quick preview we actually not so
much Grant funded in the Medicaid and
Medicare program um we're actually uh
it's a different type of funding than
that it's um I'm not sure I have the
technical name but it's not subject to
the federal health clinics the those are
those are Grant or direct funded by the
federal government and they're neither
Medicaid or Medicare some of the our
providers who serve us like federally
qualified Health Centers the fq hc's do
have federal grants that could be
subject to that review other provider
types as well but our funding from the
state standpoint is not conditioned on
grants for for the basic Medicaid
Program okay I'm I I'm just trying to
make sure that the new people to
division three understand that there's
Federal money coming from multiple
sources and Medicaid Medicare or not the
universe of federal funding you rais an
important point because when you look at
who else comes before you in terms of
all different types of providers that
Medicaid funding may not be the majority
of their funding or if it is they still
rely on a significant amount of other
funding outside the Medicaid Program all
right thank
you um so the slide nine um really
breaks down into three sections the one
on the the left um there if if a state
chooses to participate in the Medicaid
Program which all states do and all the
territories
the in the first block you have to
provide the things on the left um
optional eligibility groups um and when
you use the word optional I'm not so
sure that's really the best term of art
but that's what it is um you know for
example low-income adult population the
second bullet is the Grant and Advantage
Program the third bullet speaks to Home
and Community Based Services we
obviously see as a state the benefit of
providing Home and Community Based
Services over institutional care but a
state doesn't have to have a home incub
based service program I don't know of a
state that doesn't because the
preference of the clients and the the
preference of uh um from a cost
standpoint then um some Medicaid
individuals have both Medicaid and
Medicare um and we call those people
dual
eligibles and so um typically um there
are two major ways that people who are
Medicare also get medic
it's because they have a a disability
like they're they're blind um would be
one as an example or they have some
major disability or that they're very
low income and they can't afford the the
cost sharing that goes along with
Medicare and so they they at a low
enough income that there's um assistance
that's available through the state and
the federal government to to support
them accessing their Medicare benefit
and then finally on the right um is the
regular Medicare program which um I
think probably most of you are familiar
with but generally it's when you're over
65 years of age um you become eligible
or you have a specific condition like
endstage Ral disease or certain people
with extensive disabilities can also get
earlier a question represent Stringham
uh on the optional eligibility groups
are those ones that we offer in New
Hampshire we offer all of these and do
you get the same um uh
Financial um same type of matching that
you have for the mandatory um generally
50% so we do get additional um and we'll
cover that later we have a chart on that
um but uh just like for example granted
Advantage it's
90% um the level that we go up to
covering children for that that Delta
above the required we get uh
65% but we have a chart we'll cover
later so so before we leave this with
these four that we provide on
optional if they have a specific name
that we're used to hearing would you say
the name so that we can match
descriptions to titles sure um let me
start with the ones that come to the top
of my head first um the second bullet is
the granite Advantage Program um HCBS or
home and commity based service CFI is
under that uh uh program would probably
be the most common way that um choices
for Independence this is the third
bullet um wait wait wait third bullet is
uh would be choices for Independence
would be fall under that that's probably
one of the major ones there um and then
um the last bullet um breast and
cervical cancer you you'll see on the um
the report you get monthly on our the
dashboard there's a I know the print's
small but there's a line of the
different eligibility groups but breast
and cervical cancer is um that's another
one where we get a 90% match so we would
call out significant eligibility group
yeah Family Planning um is a limited
benefit um which is that's what we call
it um and then up top
um I think here we're talking about
um um there's special in terms of the
the titles of them let me Circle back
I'll I'll email you the exact names I
doesn't want to butcher them but
basically here we're talking about um
covering um pregnant women um and uh
certain um the DD popul sure but it
doesn't have a program title that we can
hang they they do I just don't remember
them off the top of my head okay if you
could let us know later I'll definitely
you know I I just uh because we
don't we don't regularly dive into the
details but we get used to bouncing the
names of the programs around each other
yes we'll give you like a little cheat
sheet on that okay thank you and unless
it's on another slide um it isn't I
think in the form that would be best for
you to have it so we'll we'll we'll make
that resource available thank
you there are any other questions I'll
I'll jump to the next one go ahead um
the next slide on slide 10 I'm not going
to spend a lot of time on I think there
was a question uh Mr chairman when we
were you know planning for the meeting
here a bit that kind of what's the
history of the Medicaid Program began in
1965 but this chart sort of um
highlights the the key things that have
happened over time you know some of them
um the the major ones that have helped
people in our our state like for example
the the HCBS waiver the CFI program
waiver opportunity Katie Becket for
severely disabled children um and
obviously um you know around 2008 a
couple big things there um the Olstead
decision which dealt with you know
provide care in the least restrictive
environment um and obviously the of ACA
enacted in 2008 um and then obviously at
the end of this is the The Continuous
enrollment that was available during the
federal Public Health Emergency you know
New Hampshire completed its unwind a
while ago and uh um you know I think uh
before Congress and we'll get to this
later in the presentation though there's
a lot of activity potential in Medicaid
federally so I've seen this section uh
1115 waiver referred to many times in
our in our program so I I suspect you're
going to talk about that more but how
about how about the omstead decision do
we have any specific uh tie-ins to that
or probably uh when um you hear the
presentations on
ltss the division of long-term services
and support they're probably better to
speak to that than I am
moving to slides 11 and 12 I shared
slide 11 um most of it last week in the
commissioner's overview and I think
what's important to highlight again is
that the Medicaid Program really is a
Lifeline for the rest of the department
and even beyond for some of our sister
agencies um the medicate is not only the
funer but it's also plays the integral
role in collaborating on the
programmatic implementation of so much
um so many of our programs across the
department and um part of that ties into
if you go into the next slide in slide
12 into our road map which the
commissioner and and everyone who's been
up here has mentioned um in all of our
presentations really looking at how
Medicaid integrates into whether it's
Medicaid to schools or the adult and
youth Community re-entry or the healthy
moms and Healthy Babies programs the
11:15 waivers that we'll dive into later
on
um it's really important that that part
of our agency is that with Henry's team
at the table with all the different
divisions that were able to collaborate
and really leverage the value of these
uh federal funds to better serve the
residents of New Hampshire it's um the
way that we can look at what the
different funding sources are for the
different division programs and where
the money is coming from means that
we're able to to get the most um bang
for our buck if you will
so on slide 12 I I see Medicaid to
schools is is there going to be a
specific slide or two on on Medicaid to
schools or or is this the only reference
to it in the deck there'll be a a later
reference that I'll talk to about it um
but um if you want I can just briefly
cover something I don't want to throw
you off your Rhythm I I just I just
don't want to um have us Overlook the
importance of division 3 understanding
the medication to schools program sure
um I think later on would be better to
fit it in if that's okay very good
ahead so we're getting to part two now
the eligibility enrollment um so um on
page uh 14 slide 14 um we have I'm going
to walk you through just a a few areas
of Eligibility and uh how New Hampshire
kind of stacks up
um as you may recall in um the 2023
legislative session um the uh
legislature approved uh expanding
postpartum care from 60 days to uh to to
12 months um and um also um did some
eligibility changes for for children
um the um
so far again because I don't know how
much more depth we're going to get into
as we're going let let me ask uh my
question about this here so I I was part
of the support for the extending this to
12 months postpartum and that God I
don't know if that was last year or two
years ago because everything blurs um
but um do we have any data to help us
understand about the utilization and the
incremental incremental cost associated
with the the utilization of the
additional benefit we do um that's part
we've been reporting to Health and Human
Service oversight you know the initial
things the you know the approval from
the legislation was in June we were able
to get a state plan Amendment effective
October of uh 23 we started covering
under this benefit you know it takes a
little while to you know get enough
experience I think we're getting close
there and we plan to as we come forward
to have more information about that
we'll have the number of people that
have have been able to take advantage of
that benefit and um over time we'll be
able to also look at um some of the key
um benefits of it you know uh just to
throw out a couple statistics here that
aren't on the slide deck that um in
terms of postpartum um deaths in in New
Hampshire that um while you saw earlier
only 22% of the births are from uh in
Medicaid uh over 50% of the deaths that
occur are individuals who are covered by
Medicaid for for both mental health and
substit use disorder reasons um also
when you look at um cardiovascular
conditions I'm sorry are are you
conflating a couple of things it's it
sounds like you may be we're we're we're
talking specifically about the
postpartum care and you're talking about
50% suicide are you are you saying that
most of most so that 50% is due to poor
or inadequate postpartum care so the
availability of it to get all your
postpartum care needs done in 60 days
which has been historically what we've
provided if you try to just get a
doctor's appointment today it's it's and
to get your your needs met so that's a
yes or a no I tried to ask a yes or no
question okay let me let me try again um
in terms of the the benefit yes is tied
to what I was saying maybe I need to
explain the statistics I was sharing
better yeah okay cuz this is a
relatively new benefit and we should be
looking at it
during this budget cycle I I I think
there was good reason for us to support
it we just need to understand the actual
impact of the of the service
representative Edwards if I may just get
to what you said yes sir the answer to
your question is yes so from the deaths
this past uh year year that were within
12 months of the maternal morbidity of
the deaths of mothers who died within 12
months of delivering their their child
the majority of those deaths were as a
result of either substance use disorder
or
suicide and those happened by in large
part after the 60 days of Medicaid
coverage was completed now with Medicaid
coverage exceeding for one year the hope
is this is where we'll be looking at the
data to come is that those individuals
will have access to life-saving
medications like medication assisted
treatment for opiate use disorder and
will not have a relapse and uh die from
opioid overdose so that yes so it sounds
like a great program are you maintaining
the distinction between suicide and sud
death so because I I I I don't want to
conflate those
if if they're
distinct they are distinct there are
many individuals who have we call
co-occurring disorders those that have a
mental health illness as well as a
substance use disorder right um and we
have in this state a maternal morbidity
Review Committee that looks at each and
every single death right and does a very
deep dive into the causes of all those
deaths and informs us the Medicaid
Program and other areas of the state of
what can be done
differently uh to prevent such deaths in
the future okay I would imagine most of
suicide we can follow up with you on
that all right thank you did you have a
okay so new New Hampshire was not alone
in in adopting this um Idaho last month
was a state one of the later states to
make the 48th state that have adopted
this coverage um and so that that
coverage is this is at the same level
across the country in terms of the 138%
of the federal poverty limit when you um
come down just to the next section there
pregnant women um less than an equal to
200 1% of the federal poverty
limit with respect to covering women
under that section um we are the 34th
highest income limit um but with within
10% of the state median um so our our
our eligibility there is if you will a
little tighter than what you would see
as being the median in the country
whereas if you um look at children um we
have the fifth highest eligibility level
in the country at 323 per of the
poverty um and then the the final uh
group I put on here was the um the
granted Advantage population um 41
states are at 138% the District of
Columbia has some special um waiver in
place to cover a little higher than that
but basically it's a standard program at
138% I I I have another question for you
on the U on the bottom page 14 in the
middle it talks about a granted
Advantage with less than 138%
of federal poverty level yes is that a
cliff or is that um is is there is there
sort of a declining rate at which I I
don't know how we would do a declining
rate but so I'm assuming a cliff but I I
I hoping you'd confirm that yeah if
you're if the only reason you know
Medicaid's generally a categorical
program but if you're just lwi income
which granted advantages yeah it's a
cliff at
138 after 138 you're not eligible for
Medicaid unless you have a categorical
reason you may be able to um get
exchange coverage um that's an outside
of Medicaid that's the federal um
exchange but uh it is a cliff in terms
of
Medicaid but we have some some
supplementary programs around it for
those that are like at 139 140% there
there are other Alternatives and options
still not if not if it's you're
qualifying just based on income H
questions anyone go ahead representative
Daniels thank you for clarification the
the pregnant women that we talk about is
that irrespective of the marital status
yes marital status isn't one of the
criteria for eligibility um family size
though when we look at household income
is is a factor
so and and do you look just at the
income of of the woman or do you look at
the family income we look at the
household we go even there could be
living arrangements where it's not just
a marriage right so we look at both
thank
you all right thank thank you uh are you
on slide 15 I am um and this I think uh
to representative Daniel's earlier
question uh the current federal poverty
limits uh that are going into effect for
2025 um and um had put them into
um and one only went up to a household
size of four you could keep on going um
beyond that but though just to be
illustrative here um and we have the
granted Advantage Program the pregnant
women and then the upper limit for for
uh a child one of the important things I
want to point out and which we just
talked a moment ago is about households
we when we do an eligibility at a
household level um let's say the
individual was just over the granted
Advantage limit the parent and say they
we're came in at 140 as an example of
the federal poverty limit um that parent
might not be eligible but the child
they're below the child limit so the
child could get coverage while the
parent couldn't in that instance so so M
just to make the obvious uh apparent
here um on this household size the kid
doesn't count because we're where this
household size is used to calculate
income and so we're only looking at
people of income producing age to be
part of the household yes you have to be
an adult to and what do you consider
adult well in
um there are a couple defin definitions
of adult in the in terms of the
eligibility side it's for the household
size for the household size size I think
um I just want to confirm it oh let me
give you an answer on that I believe
we're talking about over 21 um but I'll
let me confirm it because I don't do the
day-to-day eligibility sure these ages
are all over the place 18 21 24 26 yes
if I could speak to that for a moment if
that's okay so in terms of uh qualifying
as a child in New Hampshire we go up to
before you turn 19 right and then you
can pick up you could qualify for
granted Advantage except there are some
exceptions to that for example dental
coverage um a child is up to age 21
years of age if they've been in foster
care
in um they get uh special coverage up to
age 26 through up to through their age
25 ends at 26 so it's oftentimes
particularly when we're dealing with
other agencies the definition of a child
and a an adult um you know most of us
would consider a 19y old or 20-y old to
be in the adult kind of phase but that
isn't necessarily the case at each
eligibility class so if we wanted to
standardize that that's that's above the
state's level of authority right that's
that's Federal yes unless we were to get
some form of waiver which um I'm not
sure what the upside of that would be to
just to keep it simple yeah who whose
question representative tki thank you I
just wanted to make sure I understand
this chart if we could walk through a
scenario of say um a single woman who um
is at 200% of federal prop level um and
makes let's say just under that
31,44 I see correct right she's covered
yes then she has her baby and um Now we
move over to a she's now a two Family
household mm right yep and um now she
qualifies on up to $42,500 is that
correct but regardless the child no
matter what is covered because the the
infant would be covered in households up
to 60 8,000 yes am I understanding that
correctly okay I just wanted to walk
through how that all works very well
done okay thank
you and you and you know it was it was
the combined income between in your
scenario you said she was with a husband
no I didn't I said she was a single oh
at first I did say that at the beginning
I apologize okay it would I I thought I
said a single mother well the detail I
think you left out was um that if if if
the person is married it the household
in is the combined income of the of the
two correct okay yeah I thought in my
scenario I said a single mother though
okay thanks you did
both so slide uh 16 representa Stringham
I just love this math so I wanted to go
through so if it is a single mother at
30,000 um she has the baby it becomes a
two family or two-person household uh
for 12 months after delivery she'd be in
the expanded and she would be covered
but if her income was 30,000 going to
your 138%
FPL uh after 12 months she would drop
off but the child would still be covered
is that right after 12 months was the
condition you said yes okay thank
you and and this 323 per that puts us at
what the top four in the nation or
something like that fifth highest and in
the next two slides you'll get a little
bit of perspective on that too okay
represent Daniels no thank you I'd just
like to get clarification because
representative Edward's question uh what
regarding the household size the the
answer was that it is wage earners on
representative T's example you started
out with a single mom and when she had
the baby she said that now becomes a
household size of two and you said yes
but the the baby is not a wag earner so
i' like clarification in there as to so
that that both can be true um you can
have a household size in terms of who's
like um a child's income if you will
would not be counted against the the
eligibility for the mom in that instance
but I think the probably the the the
simplest way to to to get to this I
think in the example of if the woman was
single and you know the the 30,000
example right she would be eligible
because she's below the 2011
the child is added um in terms of
whether her eligibility would remain in
2011 after she did the 12 months of
continuous coverage she may drop to the
to the individual size of the granted
Advantage Program be able to potentially
pick up coverage there but if she's at
30 she wouldn't be eligible after 12
months then um the child would continue
to be eligible be because of the the
household size because the the parent
has to also provide for the child it's
not just a onep person
household so so the money that comes in
from being a medic Medicaid recipient is
is considered income no they their wages
from from employment um could it's it's
if you kind of look at your tax return
um it's the modified adjusted gross
income line of the tax return is what is
used for calculating the
okay so I'm really really slow a single
mom with a
kid is a household size of one unless
for some strange reason the kid is
making a bunch of
money no this is what I'm asking him
because I don't
understand I don't I I don't understand
why why are we counting a kid that's not
making income as part of the household
size because they have to provide for
the child um and then why do we mess
with the household size of one why don't
we start with
two there are instances I mean using
that some a single head of household
who's living alone who had a low income
that's a household of
one but the kid makes it too yes correct
but we started that she was okay I'm for
some reason I'm just baffled by that but
go ahead go ahead thank you can I maybe
I can my next question so to confirm if
I had two parents both working with two
children that would be a household size
of
four got it and though we know those two
children are not working their incomes
though are zero so their income is not
technically their income is adding to
that total but because they are minors
so the single my single mother story
with a child is a household of two yes
when the child's did that clarify
anything yes representative yeah
representative Nan I I think the
confusion is it's a pregnant woman while
she's pregnant it's one when she has the
baby it's two correct that that's where
the confusion comes I
think so in terms of taking up the the
when you come to your budget review I
think in terms of the the eligibility I
think that this this part won't really
factor in your sort of your alignment
item review only whether we had the
right
earners you ready can I okay so slides
16 and 17 um chairman Edwards was you
had when we were planning for the
meeting you would want it to see how
eligibility changed over time and um for
the Children's Group um the yellow
highlight on page 16 you can see that it
since in the last decade it hasn't
changed and you can see um how other
states are um in that regard you can see
how we're number five um if and then the
second page is on the pregnant women you
can see um here we spotted the the
median which is in the blue band about
half way a little more than halfway down
the page and you can see New Hampshire's
yellow hold on a second I'm just looking
at
it so there's clearly some discretion
here and the discretion is is different
state and we're doing very well with the
children and less well with the uh
pregnant women because we're 34th there
and fifth for the kids am I reading all
this data right yes okay all right Dr do
you want to make just referencing our
earlier chart that did did show that New
Hampshire though has a very low
percentage of pregnant women who were
covered by Medicaid compared to other
states even at the same time that we're
34th in the uh percentage of the federal
poverty limit so it's interesting that
we may have a lower percentage of the
federal poverty limit at the same time
as still having a uh High insured rate
representative stream the 255 323 and so
on set by the legislature by bills or
are they is it based on a percent of uh
poverty or how is it done these are all
federal federal poverty limits that are
standardized nationally right but the
the percentages um the our our policy
there's a certain amount of policy
choices there for example for granted
Advantage there is no choice it's a
federally dictated one for children
there's flexibility um and for pregnant
women obviously thank you do you have
any history on how we came up with 3
23% yeah you know an interesting
question I went back um some some people
may remember back in the 90s and early
2000s there was a a a group called The
New Hampshire um healthy kids
Corporation where we provided um
coverage and um going back to I think
1997 or 1998 we were at like
300% of poverty within that group and I
think that when New Hampshire uh healthy
kids Corporation went away was when
there was a an additional opportunity to
get a higher Federal match within the
state structure and um it was a
Medicaid it was serving the same
population and there was um and so I
think that's I could trace it back all
the way that far we've always I think
New Hampshire has taken an interest in
kids I think when you look at um you
know the statistics compared to um other
states New Hampshire tends to be in the
top five or even the top three with
respect to Children's Health um and uh I
think part of that is because we provide
coverage sure it's just a weird number I
I don't know why they didn't pick 320
325 why why 323 was there some
underlying rationale that you probably
don't know I'm just I actually have I
think there's an option you can go up to
318 and there what they call a 5%
disregard if if you're um looking at the
you know what the income is at a point
in time you um you have a little bit of
leeway there to to to consider it
because people's income fluctuate okay
represent torki very quick question
because I don't see it and if I it's
here I apologize I missed it the number
of grand estate children who participate
in the program um I think the next page
we've got apologies thank you great
segue thank you um so
um this gives you as of the beginning of
um January um if you look at the top the
enrollment um you the total enrollment
to the far right was just under
185,000 it typically runs a little
higher this time of year because people
who are um applying for exchange
coverage who end up not being eligible
they get referred to Medicaid we tend to
see but we've been running between 182
and about about this number um the
um the current enrollment and standard
is you know within 715 individuals um
compared to March of 2020 um the granted
Advantage Program is still running
higher than it was pre pandemic but you
know we hit almost 97,000 individuals um
at the peak of the pandemic and you
think about granted Advantage was an
income oriented eligibility a lot of
people um when the the job market seized
up for a while um were became
eligible um but um um you know along the
left hand side going under where the
words point in time are different um
categories the the children um we
covered you know close to 90,000
children um terms of the child group um
you can see that's sort of the the
bottom half of that chart there are the
different categories for
children um and then the various other
other groups here there are other ways
that this can be broken down but this is
the way we commonly uh track it in the
group I I think I understand this chart
all except for the far right column that
says a change from
328 right so that was the the time that
we began the from the time we began the
unwind how much the change has been in
enrollment if you go on to the bottom
328 24 or 23 23 um that uh we're you
know a little over
66,000 fewer than at the peak I had just
forgotten my
dates it's understandable all right um
the page
19 it's just a on the left hand side is
a map of which states have adopted the
41 States plus the District of Columbia
on the right um there is a little bit of
uh information about
um please on on the map there so there
are nine states that didn't do expanded
medicaid so do you have any idea of
what's going on for the eligibility
group that got missed as a result what
what what like what is Texas doing to to
handle the people people that we would
have qu qualified as eligible that they
and they don't even have the
program on you know uninsured is higher
uncompensated care Texas um in I think
2018 got a special waiver to help with
uncompensated care from the federal
government um but generally they these
states have higher uncompensated care
than the New Hampshire higher level of
un uninsured U Wisconsin has
had a hybrid program that they have not
wanted to change from but um they have
something that's close to it but doesn't
quite go up to
138%
um and an Our number for expanded
medicaid is that the adult expansion the
yes and I expect that number to you know
as as the sort of plays through over the
course of the year to for that to come
down a little bit more right but one
thing that I would note that we noticed
as going through the
pandemic um period um Public Health
Emergency period is that um some people
who are um have developed a
disability it takes a while to clear
either Social Security or other
Department's level of of of review
because we're a uh 209b state that won't
I'll save that for another day to talk
about but um the um that people who may
be in a bad way can and they're they're
not able to work anymore because of the
disability they can get granted
Advantage um and as they're working
their way through getting a more
permanent disability so we've seen I
think more of that um over time um in
terms of people understanding that that
path is available to them and if you
look at the right hand side and that
sort of um pinkish purplish uh chart
that um across the top are our percent
of federal poverty limit where people
are eligible in terms and there's two
really we have two groups of granted
Advantage um individuals there's the
regular group and then there are people
who are what we call medically frail um
often these are people who may have a
severe mental health condition
um but um you can see that there are uh
when you look at the total um enrollment
for the period we ran that there are
quite a few people that are actually
even below um um you know 100% of
poverty um and a good chunk that are
between zero and 50% of
poverty and I I'd also note that we've
kept track of some statistics in terms
of how many people over the last decade
have IND Unique Individuals have taken
advantage of that program it's over a
quarter of a million individuals in the
state um Unique Individuals that have
program I'm curious
um under Medicaid the granted Advantage
Program the federal government's paying
90% of that care I believe correct okay
and we have in our law a trigger that if
the feds opt to pay us
80% or less then that automatically
terminates our granted Advantage program
is that is that accurate it it's
actually if the trigger is just purely
at 90% that there's a notice requirement
immediately to the legislative
leadership and then there's a 180 day um
sort of wind down of it that that's
what's in the current law so anything
under 90% we our program starts to roll
up yes I think the legislature obviously
extend it that's why we have 180 days or
whatever yes and as well as you know
just to have a reasonable transition for
people if were to happen so so is there
a reasonable transition for people what
happens if that program goes away and we
have uh six months to to do something or
not well I I think um there are a few
different factors here at the individual
person's level right there if there's a
large part of the population if they're
only income eligible they they're not
going to have an option because if
you're below um a certain level of
poverty you you can't even get ACA
coverage they just would be out of luck
I think the other thing to keep in mind
and address this a little bit further on
um but I think I should speak to it now
at least a little bit that if you look
at how New Hampshire's overall health
insurance Market has has operated we've
we um have in combination with the
insurance Department's 1332 waiver and
having a an expansion group an expansion
group we see a lot more mental health
and and behavioral health conditions and
if the the that group were to go away I
think and this is where I say even if
you're not on Medicaid you benefit from
the granted Advantage Program because I
think it's helping between the 1332
waiver and the granted Advantage group
it it pulls theis risk pools better for
the private Market to operate and the
ACA exchanges in terms of the cost of
the individuals the there's a higher
cost here than um than would be in the
ACA today and we've you know New
Hampshire's been either the lowest or
among the the two or three lowest on ACA
um Benchmark coverage and so I think
that
there's it's it won't be a good thing if
it's terminated for the for the state
for the individuals I think for our
Insurance markets and the costs for
others um and um but I also understand
that you know there there was a trigger
put in for a purpose and the policy
makers have have hopefully within that
180 day period have a chance to consider
do okay thank you the and made a
point um it would also be a an
incredible burden on our healthc care
system our local hospitals or critical
access hospitals our provider groups
with the increase of people likely in
the util uh Ed utilization and
uncompensated Care increase if this if
this eligibility group went away all
right so actually on slides 20 and 21
I'm sort of jumped ahead a little bit
making the point but just uh slide 20 is
uh from the New Hampshire Department of
Insurance annual report on the market
and I highlighted in yellow there the
the parts where Medicaid participates
but also in the footnotes one of the
things to to notice about New
Hampshire um is that in terms of
employer sponsored insurance we have
among the highest rates of employer
sponsored Insurance in the state which I
think is a good thing for um you know
the availability of insurance in in our
state um and
then um on page 21 uh you know sort of a
demonstrated a reduction in um The
Benchmark premiums for the individual
Marketplace coverage that we saw a
15.6% reduction um in the 20 to 21
period and that's sustained that we
operated lower than the United State
average and and New England average um
so I guess the point I'm trying to make
here is that there is I think some
correlation between having the risk
pools in the proper category based on
the way they utilize services and that
if Medicaid expansion were to go away
the grant Advantage Program there could
be effects on this for not people on
Medicaid but
everybody so this is a really unexpected
result right nobody has complained about
their family health premium going down I
don't I never hear that I just always
hear that Health premiums are going up
and this seems to indicate that in fact
it's going down so this is the ACA uh
coverage and for ACA the
americ the afford act the Affordable
Care Act and this is The Benchmark
premium that they evaluate States on um
and um you know I think why while you
while we've we're certainly in a lot
better position than we've ever been the
cost sharing in these plans is still
pretty high and people people's out of
pocket costs all right so this isn't
showing the deductible and stuff this is
just showing the the premium cost yep
and so the premium standardize so the
total cost of the health insurance is
maybe still going up but while the
premium looks like it's not right I mean
I think it's a Apples to Apples
comparison but it isn't the whole apple
right a lot of worms in the apple and
and you've mentioned 1332 a few time
when are you going to teach us what a
1332 is so um this is within the
insurance Department's uh sphere but
I'll try to do U something with it uh
that hopefully will be helpful here um
so the way the insurance Market gets
priced um that each individual health
plan when they have high cost cases they
have to figure in their premium when
they set their premium that um that they
might get one of these high cost cases
the 1332 waiver is helps provide some
protection so that they can uh uh set a
lower premium because they not exposed
to all the risk and so more than that I
don't think I can do it justice is
probably the insurance department but
effectively it's a risk sharing
mechanism with the federal government
and the state and and the and the
providers to um you know not have to
price as high for those extraordinary
cases right it's insurance for the
insurance yes okay and we just uh and
the insurance department recently got
this renewed um this year okay
representative end of last year uh just
back on on slide 18 um mgia and Ng M
what's the uh acronyms for that I think
I know but I rather hear it from you
it's it's just a a code in our system
and we probably should have printed that
out further but mgia is the regular
Granite Advantage um and MGM is people
who have identified that they're
medically frail um typically that um if
this was pertinent at a point in time
when um people could choose
be outside of the Managed Care Program
um this goes back ways that um people
had particularly um difficult medical
conditions they could choose to be out
and we had the premium assistance
program for a short period of time in
New Hampshire where we did private
mcos um separate followup if it's okay
the um just just a reminder as long as
long as you're consistent with your
questioning you can just keep going uh
you you also talked about uh you know
what happens if if where do these people
go we we had a lot of people drop off
Granite State Advantage uh at the end of
the pandemic how did they do and um we
learned from that so A number of them
were able to get uh either employer
sponsored Insurance um there are some
statistics out there on that um I just
don't have them off the top of my head
but um
in terms of the number of people covered
in the individual Market that's um that
went up um not not the whole Delta but I
think somewhere over
20,000 individuals from like the during
the pandemic period but we can do a
little research to provide you a better
answer there um but um you know
fortunately because those people that
had a drop that because New Hampshire
had the lowest exchange coverage in the
country or the second lowest during that
that time they had an option that was as
cost effective as you could find out
there um and then also employer
sponsored Insurance also became
well so I think flipping through this
we're done talking about the
184,000 plus that are covered by
Medicaid I think we can jump to the next
is there a well I I had a a question
still okay so the
184 uh Plus
is divided between three uh Managed Care
organizations in New Hampshire right
every Medicade person is serviced by
one uh
MCO with with a few small Exceptions
there are certain like American Indians
can um there's uh certain protected
groups and they're very small it's like
and then there are people who have
In-N-Out Medicaid you've heard that
issue if you're you're only getting
Medicaid Eligibility once you incur a
certain amount of medical expenses so
there about 2,000 people of um in the
Medicaid Program that are um not in the
manage Care organizations because either
they're not consistently in so do we pay
for them separate as a fee for service
yes okay so the other 182 is in one of
the three mcos I think all
184,000 here are in the MC's
um but you just told me about 2,000 that
2,000 aren't I I think that we we're
capturing here this is the total
Medicaid populations say 182,000 that
are probably in the mcos and and 2,000
outside of it okay and then generally
how do people find which MCO they're in
is that a a completely optional election
or is that an assignment what what is
that it it's both um you can choose um
you can on our website you can can find
out about what the offerings are of the
the mcos or if you don't make an
election we do um an automatic
assignment to one of them um and we're
um part of the reprocurement we had a
period of time where people um and we're
just about ending it where people who
were on assign would go to the MCO that
was not at a um a population level we
feel like 50,000 is where you need to be
in the state to to have a break even
break financially viable um MCO and so
um Amer Health which was the new entrant
we we had a period where we did this
before the pandemic they went well above
50,000 but then post pandemic
um they fell considerably below that to
like 30,000 something so we've the
unassigned members I think they're
they're just under 49,000 today so once
we hit the 50,000 threshold we'll go
back to the
every third person um goes to one or the
other but people do choose open
enrollment period all three of the mcos
cover the exact same eligibility yes
because that's in contract Thou shalt
provide the following
eligibility so so to the extent that
there's
competition they're competing on the
basis of service quality and reputation
with interacting with the providers yes
okay just trying to understand that
market a little and the members and what
about the members well they would also
be competing upon among for their
service quality reputation to the
members right because the members can
self- select right which y right they
can change every year okay that's great
like I said this isn't educational I I
don't know how many of us actually
really understand how this Market Works
how it's paid for and and so thank you
again in for the
education go ahead okay so we're on
slide 23 now um getting into the what's
covered in um so there are mandatory
requirements to be covered under on the
left hand side of page 23 the mandatory
Services categories on the right hand
side are quote optional um and I
highlight we highlighted the ones in
yellow that are typically considered
part of the essential benefit package um
in the under the um Affordable Care Act
but you know I can tell you um back in
the I think probably the late 90s um
during a budget time New Hampshire
decided to um reduce the number of
prescriptions that could be filled um
there's actually a study in the New
England Journal of Medicine about what
the consequence of that was was that um
more people ended up being
institutionalized because they didn't
get their medications that they needed
so when you look think about like
Pharmacy as the first one on the list
being optional you know when you look at
today and we'll have a slide later on
that prescription drugs are a very major
part of the program almost approaching a
third um so that you know to provide the
things on the left without providing the
prescription drugs would would not be
such a good outcome some of the other
services like eyeglasses and hearing
aids you know reflect the the the
population um and uh um you know when
you go down this list is really not so
to understand the word optional this is
optional to the state yes not optional
to the Managed Care Organization correct
the all of these are now mandatory
because we have a state law that says
they they need to provide these so they
were optional to us the legislature not
to the MCO correct
okay uh go ahead can you explain then
why um the dental is considered optional
I thought we had Medicaid dental
coverage so it was a a choice to provide
for kids it's not a choice but for
adults it was a choice to to provide
adult dental coverage um you have to
provide like Emergency Care like if
someone had an infection and you know
that was going to cause a systemic issue
we'd pull teeth and such right now we
have a real adult Dental benefit that
was an optional choice on the part of
the state um will since you asked the
question I sorry okay I miss reading the
chart then yeah the fact that it's not
highlighted means that it was our
optional choice to give it to add it to
the program right and all of these are
actually optional what I by highlighting
I was just showing the ones that are
considered mandatory in the um exchange
coverage space that okay I'm sorry I
misunderstood the list thanks um the
dental program you know from your budget
standpoint um is there was a settlement
that uh came in as a result of some um
work that the department had done with
uh one of the mcos
and through this bym coming up the the
cost of the adult Dental benefit will be
still be able to be picked up by that uh
that
settlement so that was that centin money
was thought to last us through this
budget cycle and I think that's still
the forecast yes yeah U I had
representative Stringham first and then
I'll come back to you representative
Angel uh
Topic near and dear to a heart where do
ambulance services fit in under this
chart or do they they do um they're
they're
[Music]
um they're covered in our contract under
the the transportation um area but it's
I guess would fall under sort of
emergency um and patient oh patient
hospitalization would be where we'd
would would probably fit it in this I
guess their
you know it it could be detailed out
further but just try to capture the
broad
categories representative Daniels thank
you for someone who is dual eligible is
Medicare or Medicaid the primary um
typical typically it's Medicare that's
primary for someone who's over 6 65 and
older um there are times I think with
some of the the the waivers that it may
be reverse um
does that hold true for the under under
65 with the disabilities too I I think
that I need to it's not my area of full
expertise so but I believe that there
are certain instances where Medicaid
could be primary but dual eligibles when
we're talking about Medicare Medicaid
we're picking up the the deductibles um
and the co-payment
percentages okay so if I just understood
you to say that Medicaid you you
you Medicaid are picking up the
deductible so you're the primary so
we're secondary in that instance right
you represent solki you look okay I fell
for the head
fake um so we'll continue with slide go
ahead
okay Medicaid to schools I just I think
this might be a point where I could jump
in and and talk about that for a moment
um so Medicaid to
schools um and are you on 24 you know
what I think actually I'm going to let
you're still on 23 I'm gonna have
Jonathan go now and then I'll I'll come
back to it I think when we get to the
next section okay we'll continue on then
with slide number 24 which is uh
explaining that category a little
further that's on page 23 of the early
periodic screening Diagnostic and
treatment for children it's commonly
referred to as
epsdt um that's an interesting acronym
what it really is though is that any
child that is covered by the Medicaid
Program it's mandatory for the state to
cover not only what's sort of normal
Medical Services or normal medications
that are on our state formulary but for
any can any treatment that helps a child
uh maintain function or could be
improving for them this is often times
uh some type of a piece of medical
equipment or durable medical good uh and
I point this out because this is a
catchall
category and if you ever have a
constituent uh of yours a child that's
covered by Medicaid and they're having
difficulties covering something this is
where we use our discretion so these
cases come to myself and to the Medicaid
medical directors uh on a Case by casee
basis we're small enough state that we
actually review every single one of
these situations to determine whether or
not something that is outside the norm
that would be of a medical benefit or
just to keep the child at their normal
level of functioning uh is a coverable
service so continue
on so moving into um so so was that
wasn't the schools the Medica going pick
that up in this section coming up here
all right thanks so so key financing
isues um on the left hand side of slide
26 um when we make a payment to a
provider I think as we've talked about
it's a a partnership between the state
and federal government um that we each
contribute towards effectively paying
the provider um and so that the amount
that each of the the the yellow circle
and the green circle um contribute in a
particular situation is um it changes
based on different factors which I'll
get
into
um the you'll sometimes hear the term
fmap as an acronym it's the federal f um
Federal Medical Assistance percentage
it's the percentage that can be drawn
the actual uh payment is the federal
participation I don't know why they have
two different acronyms to basically
basically describe the same thing but
you might hear ffp or or fmap
essentially they're the the same thing
um but um in terms of
um fmap which we'll get into a little
bit uh it's varies by state um in terms
of the minimum fmap and we'll we'll look
at that in a moment um but then the last
bullet in the the square there um under
state federal share there's different
percentages for different activities
Medicaid schools is kind of a somewhat
unique um in terms of the federal
match the way that um it has worked in
New Hampshire is that U Medicaid
reimburses schools for services that are
in the what I'll call the plan whether
it's an IEP plan or some other so so so
the way you said that sounds like a
direct relationship between the federal
government and the schools bypassing the
state no um because the they have to
build
Medicaid um for the the services that
they they provided school does um but
instead of paying them if the say the
fee schedule amount for a service was
$100 we would pay them
$50 and the the federal government
considers what the school is
contributing towards the service is the
part they don't get paid um and so
um today the we federal government has
advised New Hampshire and other states
that um that the federal government
wants to pay half the cost and so that
our fee schedule actually is probably in
many
instances um lower than their full cost
so they're really not getting half the
cost so by the end of uh State fiscal
year
26 we need to convert to um
a different methodology for claiming
funds which I want to you know from a
good standpoint um will provide the
opportunity to have schools be able to
claim for coverable services under
Medicaid to schools 50% of their real
costs um and so they'll be filing um
I'll call a cost report of some kind and
um we'll pay them on an interim basis
and then we'll up to what their actual
costs were and so we we got a Federal
grant to help us with the implementation
of that which we hope does not get um
involved in um not being we've got some
of the money already we're hoping it
continues to be paid but um we're in the
middle right now of doing a request for
proposal to um do a procurement to uh
support schools with a vendor to to uh
implement this new claiming methodology
it's it's a fairly common methodology uh
but in New
Hampshire um we're sort of a bit late to
that that game and I think it's for
reasons that uh how we do funding versus
some other states um and um so schools
will um will provide the services as
they do today that fit within the
Medicaid to school space they'll they'll
still build like they do today but will
settle up against their actual costs um
at a time um after the the particular
year is completed could you provide us
with a list of the things that schools
can um provide services for so I think I
can brought a little clarity about the
Medicaid to schools know essentially
schools have requirements to provide uh
Educational Services to students that
fit within the individualized education
plan so you'll hear that term a lot
IEPs many of those are though medical
services that fit within treatments like
uh that fit within treatments that we
would cover in in a doctor's office or
another type of enrolled Medicaid
providers offices already so these are
services that the schools are required
to provide to the student already and
what Medicaid the schools does is that
is then just as you say for those types
of services is able to provide 50 % of
those costs to the school so it helps
alleviate the budget pressure at the
local level using these federal funds so
so most of the money that's going to the
schools for through this program most of
it like over 90% are related to Services
related to the IEP the students IEP
there there are a couple of of different
classified plans but IEP is a good
rubric to describe the the group of
things
so so what percentage generally goes due
to IEP 2/3 no all all of it has to fit
within a plan there are different types
of plans which I'm not expert on within
the school environment um that and I can
give you a list of them I just don't
remember all the acronyms off the top of
my head and I don't want to acronym you
to death here but the IEP the individual
education plan it's for services that
are health related that support the
child to be able to get an education so
we don't have a problem with the IP
we're just trying to understand the
universe of services that schools are
able to build Medicaid for and I keep
hearing IEPs as though that was
everything and it's not let me let me um
in New Hampshire today anything that's
appropriate to the
setting um within our state plan is
available to a school so me they could
do mental health they could do
Rehabilitation they could do pretty much
anything that would be appropriate for
helping a kid get the education that
they need it could be because of a
physical disability it could be a
learning disab and the schools are set
up to provide mental health
counseling they they probably provide a
limited amount of that but but if they
needed a to Pro to to support the say
kid had a behavioral problem right that
in terms of uh because of an Autism
situation as an example and they needed
an aid to support that child in um you
know maintaining the ability to attend
the classroom that's a service that we
can pay for and before that service is
rendered the parents consent is obtained
they have to get a consent of the parent
for not only the plan but also to Bill
Medicaid and the child has to be
obviously be covered by Medicaid for Are
Family Planning Services included on the
list and are parental consent required
for them it's it's um I'm not a I'm not
aware that Family Planning would fall
within a plan in order to help a child
meet their education plan it would
Landry sorry I just I if I could just
jump in I just think it's really
important to distinguish this is not a
health care clinic within a school
system that children with Medicaid are
eligible eligible to receive services
this is strictly Medicaid covered
Services as as Dr bad highlighted that
are there to support the child's
education plan that's determined between
the parents the child if it's
appropriate for the child to be involved
that conversation and the School
administrator so you're you're coming
back to that 100% of the medic Cade
money is in support of an
IEP or equivalent plan it may not be
called an IEP in some plans but it it is
it's usually called an i p sometimes
it's a 504 um I'm not I'm not sure4 is
one of the 504 IP is so it's for those
services that are covered by Medicaid
for a Medicaid child but for the sake of
making them successful in school so this
isn't if a child who has Medicaid can't
just go get healthc Care at the at the
school I think it's really important to
distinguish it these are strictly
services covered in their education plan
determined by the parents this and the
the school counselor teacher whomever
those um appropriate school yeah
Administration and and that's what's
covered and and this the Medicaid
school's funding takes the burden off
the schools and this new program in fact
puts more money in the school's hands
which is really critical to help offset
these costs because as we know you know
Education costs are that's a burden as
well and there's a lot of costs that the
schools need to cover I think I think
most people who look at this U like the
idea that if there's a medically
appropriate Services helping with the
education plan that it's good to go
ahead and take advantage of the federal
reimbursement what what what happens
though is
sometimes there's a vacuum of knowledge
and information about it and people hear
it and jump to conclusions and they're
concern that we're setting up miniature
clinics in the in the schools and that
by doing that we're circumventing
parental knowledge of what's going on
with their kids so I'm asking you these
questions in sort of a harsh way to make
sure I understand exactly the Precision
of the boundaries between what's in and
what's out so that I can help you know
I'll just admit it that most of it's
within my party that has cynicism about
this and so so I need to understand this
is all I thank you I'm chairman Edwards
I I I hear that question and that's why
I really want to be very clear that this
is not healthc care clinic in a school
system this is Medicaid covered services
for children who have an education plan
and this is required for them to be
successful in class but thankfully
Medicaid covers these Services despite
that it's coming um in a in education
setting this is totally separate I think
Medicaid of schools it's almost the two
this is giving Medicaid funding to the
school systems to cover the services are
required for a school for child to be
successful so so gender transitioning um
counseling is not part of what would
make up an
IEP no I mean I I believe to um Henry's
points autism Maybe
um so I mean I I think of my own I'm so
sorry I'm almost embarrassed to have to
ask these questions but these are the
questions that pop up in the wild that I
need to be able to deal with and I so I
I just appreciate it and I know there
are other questions by now
representative Daniels thank you I
haven't heard you mention it
specifically but uh does the the
Medicaid Support also include the outof
district placements
uh that could cost hundreds of thousands
of
dollars so in terms of some aspects are
not coverable by Medicaid like the
residential component of it but if they
have medical needs and Dr balad deals
with this more frequently than me so
I'll let him frequently involved in a
case-by case basis for children with
these specialized needs that are not
being able to receive the the Medical
Services usually is uh a component of it
that is not able to be met in the
setting at school and so those
situations then we frequently will meet
with um the family or area agencies that
are assisting families uh and school
districts and whenever those situations
arise it's a bit of figuring out what
component of those out of District
Services fit within the bucket of
medical services in for Medicaid
Medicaid cannot pay for room and board
uh in out of District settings and
that's a a significant component uh so
allowable thank you I was just looking
to take a couple steps backwards and was
maybe going to try to um ask for some
specific examples for example I know
that a school I worked in had an OT room
for occupational therapy that's a very
common one that's a very common one um
what other services are we talking like
speech therapy yes yes some other
Physical Therapy Physical Therapy a
school nurse who's um like a child may
have a medical condition that's one of
the plans that it may be that their
medical condition they need insulin
children with diabetes is often times a
case requires medical services at school
okay someone who has a chronic medical
condition like that so my second part to
this question now that I have that
Clarity on the types of services we're
actually talking about is if a child has
private insurance does this this maybe
isn't even in your department of
expertise but does the school district
build private insurance for if they have
needs I I don't there may be variation
in practice there I don't feel I know
enough about that to to give you a good
answer question for another committee
see I think that's an excellent question
is are is
Medicaid uh covering a cost that the
private insurance should as well well
that wasn't necessarily my question
because we're we're talking about two
groups of children we're talking about
children covered by Medicaid and then
we're talking about children covered
under private insurance right that's one
group to me n grou they're called
they're called students in the school no
you have 880,000 children 990,000
children in the granite state covered
under Medicaid and that's what we're
talking about here that receive these
services but there are likely a large
number of children who are under private
insurance through their parents employer
who also receive services to to meet
their IEP and I'm wondering if School
districts receive reimbursement through
those private insurers for those
services and I'm assuming the answer so
my question is are the school's even
trying to build them I don't know that's
a question I think for maybe Commerce
what committee I don't know Commerce or
or I don't know representative stringam
I would guess that they're not covered
OT is not not covered to be paid for by
the school system
typically if it's a traditional
elementary school middle school high
school something like
that it would be helpful I can try to
get some information back to the
committee on that I think I went down
another road but you answered my first
part which was I wanted specific
examples of those Services we're
you represent go ahead yeah
representative Neno so I'm a little
confused two questions here is whether
it's covered and whether if it's being
built out if it is covered I mean there
are two aspects that I've understood
representative T's uh question or
representative edwards's question is
that is that uh fair to say there really
two questions there is it if it's
covered by private insurance is it being
build out to the
private that's a question which these uh
professionals are not actually the ones
to answer that
question there's a coverage question
first of all and then there was the the
billing
question but regarding private pay
insurers that's not in their purview
yeah all right thanks for the Deep dive
and and believe me I think it is going
to be worthwhile um representative
walner I just have one really quick
question is every school in New
Hampshire registered to be in this
program or approved to be in the program
so any any school that wants to be can
be I think we have 172 out of 1 78
school districts that participate um you
know that some really really small
school districts it may not be worth
their while based on the number of
students and the administrative cost of
it we we do um we do want to work I
think there's a lot of my my view there
are millions I'm not saying hundreds of
million but
maybe um between maybe Six and10 Million
worth of funding that I think schools
may eventually be able to Avail
themselves when we can actually
recognize their their true costs of
providing Services I will say that it's
you know
Medicaid billing and um all the
regulations around it are not a simple
thing to to work on we've we've worked
over the last number of years with the
New Hampshire charitable Foundation to
try to get extra technical assistance
beyond what the state can provide and
what we're hoping um is part of the
grant that we're getting is that we can
we're hiring a firm that's been done
this in other states that can help uh
teach the school districts how to do
this work to maximize what's uh legally
available and within appropriate plan uh
to be able to recover costs and I think
this is we're being we're having to do
it I think it's something that I've had
on my mind to want to accomplish since
I've been the Medicaid director it's
just it's it's having the the transition
is is going to it's going to be a little
bit painful to to do it but I think once
we get on the other side of it it's
going to bring more money to schools to
offset their costs great thank you that
was what I wanted to know thank you okay
um okay
so we were on uh slide oh did you have a
question yes I just want thank you Mr
chairman not to be labor the point but
this is important in fact I've had
Parents approach me and tell me they had
no clue that Medicaid was going to be
build for services and so forth so I'm
going to ask it a different way no
student without an IEP or a 504 in our
schools has things buildt to
Medicaid they the schools are required
to get the parents' consent that's
something that schools are are required
to do in order for us to receive a
billing from from them and if if a
parent has question what was provided to
their child and they need access to
their what what was build to the school
that's something they can get from
Medicaid but every child that has
something build to Medicaid in this
state has either or both an IEP and a
504 is that correct yes and there's one
other plan type that I think called bip
or something like that but it's
essentially the same kind of thing it's
to help help a kid achieve their
education either due to a health
condition that they're they're
addressing to to be able to get the
education that you know we're
constitutionally supposed to be
providing right thank
you okay one more so and I think this is
getting to your point is it's c can a a
child a student that has absolutely no
IEP no other plan walk into the school
nurse get a service that was deemed by
the nurse to be medically necessary and
have that school that's been registered
Bill Medicaid that would not be a
compliant way to access the Medicaid
you um so um I know in terms of clock
management here are we how are we doing
okay cost or time so far we're doing
good on cost
okay time okay all right so you you were
hoping to done by when whenever you
needed me to be whenever you needed us
to be done
that's have we done the hard part um
well in in some respects yes and some
respects no but let's uh let's aim at
three okay
so I think we've we've we've understand
understood from the conversation that
we've had so far that there are
different levels of financial
participation by the federal government
and I'm going to get into some of those
more I think on page 27 is just an
illustration of that uh um and but I'm
going to cover it a little bit more
detail on the slide or two ahead in page
28 real quickly here is just a a federal
map map a map of the US in terms of the
various minimum federal matching
percentages that exist today um New
Hampshire is at the lowest level because
we have the one of the highest per
capita incomes we're in New England
we're joined with Connecticut New
Hampshire and Massachusetts and in terms
of nationally there's a list of those
states that are also at
50% um some of our neighbors like
Vermont and Maine because of their per
capita income are at a higher Federal
match because they have a higher level
of poverty if you
will and I I won't belabor more on that
slide slide 29 um is just the top
portion of that is just showing examples
of the federal match that exists with
different
programs and um I I'll U hit a little
bit more on this in terms of the last
line of that top chart when I talk about
the bottom chart the the here you just
see a a concrete example mathematically
of if you're at
90% um the the state amount is 100 the
federal amounts 900 and 5050 it's
obviously half half when we talk about
and I know the legislature will be
taking up the issue of the Medicaid
enhancement tax and the disproportion
share program the dish program is
historically uncompensated care um the
state has paid out those dollars um
entirely at a 50%
match um the the opportunity to draw a
higher Federal match um uh came out of
the expiration of the of the current
Arrangement um in this last session
where the the state has the opportunity
um and to use other mechanisms to draw a
higher Federal match um you know part of
the the acceptance of what we do there
is that when you use other mechanisms
like rates and directed payments um
which directed payments are basically a
an additional payment on top of their
regular payment that while you can draw
a higher Federal match it can only be
for individuals who have Medicaid
coverage whereas dish payments can cover
um and they have to be New Hampshire
patients um when you talk about dish it
can cover Medicaid uncompensated care
cost
um uninsured costs people that don't
have insurance and it can cover someone
who um come from another state as long
as they're
Medicaid so in terms of balancing the
the what the current plan that's um
being implemented today you know pending
if there's any action this session is
that um there's a portion of it that's
paid in directed payments and in uh
rates that draws more fed Federal match
um and will support um you
know funding to bring in the 74 million
more than we otherwise would have
there's also a piece that's paid out
still in um the traditional dish program
because there are hospitals that are not
advantaged by this program they you know
if particular if you're a border state
hospital that some of your uncompensated
care for you know people who came from
another state or that if you have more
uninsured versus insured where uh we've
tried to make adjustments in our formula
to account for that I'm sure that the
there's going to be discussion this
session in on that topic um but just
suffice it to say what I'm trying to to
bring forward today as as those
discussions occur is you understand that
when you you pay out a dish dollar um it
can only be paid at 50 50% match other
choices are at a higher match but they
also have some draw for the people
receiving the funds and that you know
you can't pay out ofate Medicaid and you
can't pay for uncompensated care from
people who are have no insurance at all
that's a there's there's a lot what I
just talked about there but that is the
gist of kind of that issue in terms of
um why um some combination of the two is
favored by the by the hospitals and and
and from their perspective needed by the
hospitals
you know purely if it was just the state
perspective doing it through the other
mechanisms has advantages in terms of
the amount that we we
draw so I think represent Stringham has
a question I'd like to ask a quick
question of the audience if if you think
you would like to say something at the
conclusion of the Department's
presentation would you raise your hand
oh no I'm just asking are you going to
ask for
time okay that that's I'm sorry that was
the question I didn't say it very well
representative
Stringham uh just uh on the issue of
fmap so we're at the lowest at 50% let's
say the uh um national average is 60% if
we get if if our at map share was the
average aage we'd be looking at an extra
what half a billion to a billion in
federal money coming in I mean it's 10%
of uh of about uh we spend two and
roughly two and a half billion on
Medicaid in all parts of the department
so half of that um times like 1.2 times
it's it's a lot of money like hund and
something million
right but we can only do that if we're
poor that's we don't really have any
discrep on that unless we want to invoke
poverty well the the the federal reason
to have different rates is they believe
that uh the other states need it more is
that yeah I mean Mississippi is one of
the states that you know that where
there's more
poverty a larger percentage of the
budget is needed for Medicaid and so
they that it's it goes back to what
Congress could work out among themselves
in terms of how to Fe allocate the
dollars to meet you know the Public's
need at large um the one and I will
address this later in the presentation
you know um what we call the epilog
section in terms of there are some risks
as to whether 50% is the floor or not um
in terms of proposals before Congress
and considering do do you have a slide
where you're talking about risks yes
what we what kind of odd things we might
anticipate from this Administration 47
um the last slide okay so we'll we'll
we'll we got something to look forward
to do you have another question
represent Stringham well I just think
you know M Michigan didn't seem to me to
be the most impoverished state in the
country and it's at
76.9% so and um it's not anything I
expect you to answer but in Michigan
it's 76.9 but it
doesn't some pretty successful car
companies and other businesses in Arbor
and so on so
I I'll go back and double check that
number for for Michigan I'm sure it's
right um but uh you know I think
um in in part that's why we have a
smaller Medicaid Program because we have
less poverty
um um the next slide we covered was 29
we've covered that um so the the ability
to draw a Federal match beyond what uh
just general funds savings is through
provider taxes and fees um and on page
30 is a couple of maps in terms of uh
provider taxes and and today um you know
we talked about the Medicaid enhancement
tax um and I think um when um Chris S
and ello and the divisional long-term
Services support here they'll talk about
the nfq tax um and I'll talk about that
again on page 31 for a moment but in
terms of PR share and and the um the
equivalent of sort of dish the mquip
payment will be covered when they come
before you but uh suffice it to say that
uh New Hampshire has used provider taxes
um particularly in the the hospital area
to generate additional Federal match um
through the Medicaid enhancement tax on
page 31 can I can I get you skip forward
yes this is a a simple um I think
conceptual slide of what in order to
draw a federal match all four of these
um boxes around the fmap acronym have to
be fulfilled you have to be to claim
fmap you have to have a person who's
involved enrolled in Medicaid it has to
be a covered service under Medicaid it
has to be provided by a provider who's
enrolled in Medicaid and it has to be
medically necessary these are the four
conditions to be able to draw a federal
match so if any one of these are not
true you you're not entitled to that
Federal
match
um you want to jump ahead to um SL
35 um sure I I'm I'm looking for the
slide that says uh what we chose not to
cover in Medicaid like the long-term
supports I think is not in there so it's
coming up we have some things that
um that uh I think might get to what
your your question is in terms of what
we don't cover um because legislative
will that I I want to hear that story
about how legislatively when we were
looking at going to an MCO model we the
legislature determined to exempt
particular services from being included
in the MCO contract yes what and so is
there a slide that tells us what we left
out of the MCO yes um so if we getting
okay um so on page 43 the the top two
are in a form of Managed Care One is the
sort of the requirement to be in managed
care for most people for their regular
health insurance and then the dental um
adult dental program is in a Managed
Care
model um the 19 all the 1915 SE waivers
which is the um
inh home supports the acquired brain
disorder the DD developmental
disabilities waiver choices for
Independence are in FIFA
service now now to read that slightly
different okay uh those 1915 C's yes are
items that we could elect to put back
into the MCO
contracts technically there's a there's
a um in 20 20 I think 18 uh there was
legislation passed that prohibited um
Managed Care in this in what we call
long-term services and support space um
at one point the legislature asked the
department to do a study of it um we
brought the results back there was uh I
think concern on the part of
particularly the counties and and
providers of being in managed care and
um then um I think uh it was
representative NE Kirk I think at the
time that that put in a specific uh
legislative proposal which was adopted
that prohibited putting these services
in so when I say we can do that that
means the legislature could pass a new
law to undo the Old Law these These are
items that we could determine
legislatively to put back into the MCO
probably not this year but that would be
a discussion for the future right um
because because these things are seem to
be running at a greater rate of
increase than uh the MCO contracts are I
think in part because there was many
many many years in which there were no
rate changes and I think that you know
last legislative session those was a in
I've been in New Hampshire healthcare
for almost 40 years in terms of what I
saw as the investment that the
legislature was willing to make and and
those Services I think that's that's a
big issue in terms of the amount of
money that's being spent and I think
that the you know we saw the system sort
of collapsing around the access issue um
during the the the pandemic um when uh
when that was um active um and we had I
think providers that was saying they
were ready to quit Medicaid because they
couldn't pay their staff um and so I
think that there was a significant
investment made then
um you know again I think um you know
programmatically I support the the in
the division of Medicaid we support the
other division of long-term services and
support but they're the people that
could give you the more in-depth
understanding of kind of what what's
gone on there right I I wanted to get
this into the public hearing because
many of us are going to have people
coming to them telling them that we we
can save money if we move some of these
Services back up under the manag care
contracts and so I wanted to give you an
opportunity to sort of speak to that at
a at a high level or at least make
people aware that that's one of the
suggestions being floated yeah I mean I
think that the I can speak to it from a
couple different levels if that's okay
from the the county perspective um you
know the way that New Hampshire finances
long-term services and support is that
the counties make a significant probably
upwards of 90% or more of the the the
non-federal share and the concern there
is that um you know for example people
admitt in nursing homes that when the
managed care companies negotiate lower
rates basically means that they're going
to pay the mcos and compared to what
they're getting today they'll have
they'll get less money um there'll also
be some concerns about um you know loss
of control because they're they they're
responsible for a significant portion of
the services that are delivered they're
not only responsible for their own
nursing home but anybody who goes into a
nursing home and all the the Home and
Community Based Services they pick up a
significant portion of the of that cost
and I think that's why you know back in
18 um the concern was that the
efficiencies would come out of out of
effectively the the County's financing
perspective and I think also the private
sector was concerned um you know it's
not frequent that we hear concerns from
nursing homes and the like in terms of
their ability to make it go in New
Hampshire that concern again there that
um you know if the manag care companies
are involved in long-term service and
support on the other hand I will say
that the there is a perspective that New
Hampshire could do more outside of
institutional care and that's where the
MOs may be able to bring efficiencies to
the the situation you know New
Hampshire's try to make more progress in
that area and we have in terms of you
know uh a day in a and the home
environment is about a third of the cost
on average of a day in the institutional
environment um and you know New
Hampshire has made progress but there
are other states that have a a higher
percentage in um Home and Community
Based Services compared to to New
Hampshire but I think you know New
Hampshire has been working through ways
that it can to do that I think there's a
there's a tension there between um you
know the the maybe the most effective
cost model for the state's purchase
versus what it does to the counties and
the community Ser the community
agencies and so I think that you you'd
hear a lot about that with a Managed
Care proposal in that space But I do
think you know
ultimately um we potentially could spend
less um in in that area but states that
have gone in that Direction it's
important to leave yourself enough
Runway to implement it those states that
have rushed it have regretted it in a
big way so are are you specifically
familiar with Texas and something I
think they call the star
program um I do not know a lot about the
star program so I so there's time but um
but that's being floated as um kind of
potential model legislation for us to
look at I'll take a look at it than all
right um
all right you you can go back to where
you think you were yeah um so we've
skipped over a few pages but I think um
just in the interest of time here um you
know on P page 41 that gives you some of
the various vehicles that we can use the
the description of what they are on page
41 page 42 talks about the different
attributes of those different vehicles
for for adding service to the state um a
little education when it says section
1955 what I assume that means is if I go
to some big CMS regulation there's a
section 1 1915 1915 and I'm like
applying under that sub paragraph It's
actually the Social Security Act these
are sections from directly from the
Social Security Act oh okay great thank
you and so there are different different
flexibilities there are allowed on under
the Social Security Act to to deliver
Services um and we've used the SE
waivers are are probably our most common
ones in fact if you turn to um what
would be slide 45 I see the page number
fell off there there's a there's a
waiver wheel which Ann I think um shared
with you in the original presentation um
but these are all the things that New
Hampshire has in place that we've
um taken advantage of the state plan
being sort of the core of what we do and
then the different things that we have
in place to uh provide typically what
these waivers entail is that for certain
populations like someone who's
developmentally disabled it makes sense
to give them additional Services beyond
the traditional health insurance plan
because that's going to you know lead to
Better Health for them um and so um you
know choices for independent is
basically allowing people to you know
make a personal choice what's best for
them and to there's a cost advantage to
to to the state um you know there the in
home so so there's not enough time today
but if each of us wanted to get to
understand these boxes that are around
the wheel of the state plan these These
are documented somewhere where we can
read them and understand them hopefully
we have we have summaries of them
actually they appear in the states when
they do Bond appendix a they're in there
but we can certainly make something like
that from there available as well as
give you links to the the entire waiver
if you'd like
yeah okay I I I want to summarize
something to make sure that I understand
it and and put it into simple terms for
uh newer members um
so uh the department will come to us
with a a budget for Medicaid
that budget number as I understand it
represents your very best guess of what
our total expenditures under Medicaid
will be and you'll have factored in uh
all of our eligibilities and what the
likely populations will be there and
you'll factor in all of the um uh
utilization the the ways in which people
can get covered
care uh and and you'll do an analysis of
that and then that really drops to what
the budget request is is is that so
right so far typically I think what you
see is the agency budget next to the
governor's budget and um and then we
answer questions about about that no I'm
asking about the process I'm not I'm not
asking any dollar numbers I'm just
trying to get it straight that that the
Medicaid budget ends up having to be the
the the our best guess of the the number
of people who are eligible multiplied by
the utilization of the eligible services
and that creates a number it does but it
appears in in in in division of Medicaid
services it appears in the Managed Care
contract line 7948 of B for the Managed
Care population for nursing facilities
will appear in a different director's uh
budget but okay but and so so then the
reality is that's an estimate and if and
if we're off if for some reason
eligibility jumps or or some changes in
eligibility or um um services are are
are made then then that will drive a
number
automatically that we owe the providers
regardless of whether or not it was in
the budget if it's in excess of our
budget in other words we we kind of have
no control we have awareness and
estimates but we don't have control over
the final Medicaid spend we I would say
that we have some control we've you know
in the years that I've been Medicaid
director for seven plus years now I
think in terms of in terms of the
appropriation that's been made we've
been able to work within it based on the
estimates we developed we work with our
actuaries we um on the you know the
Medicaid Managed Care contracts so $1.2
billion total
expenditure we we put a lot of time and
effort into um developing the estimate
because if we get that number wrong
we're we're in that's almost half the
whole spend in Medicaid so um you know
that's that we've we've been able to
work within the appropriation that we've
had all all of those all of those years
and I anticipate that you know um we'll
continue to make that so what kind of
control knobs do you have then when you
say you you work within an appropriation
do you can't you can't modify the the
legal eligibility standards on the and
and and you're not changing the covered
Services what what kind of what kind of
knobs do you have to twist to to to make
adjustments after an appropriation is
done um this is the slide I wanted to
cover that we didn't which is Jonathan
we had Jonathan intended to but we have
different programs that we put in place
to help um control things if we could
let Jonathan maybe speak to a few of
those it give you some sense of you know
one of the biggest ones is is the
Pharmaceuticals you know that's 31% of
our total medical spend um and you know
we we've put new things in place with
the Managed Care contract based on the
velocity of changes that are occurring
with the prescription drug Market um but
I'll let you explain three of them if
you would sure can go over just three
many of them but so this is part of our
road map and being accountable to you
and using those uh taxpayers dollars uh
as efficiently as possible um so we know
that the pharmaceutical spend is
drastically increasing
Nationwide uh slide
see the the we let's see the py graph on
on slide 38 eight shows where your do
dollars go in
Medicaid and you'll see essentially
uh a quarter of the Medicaid spend now
goes to pharmaceutical services so it's
25% outpatient drugs and then you add in
the additional drugs that are
administered in the hospital setting and
you get up to 31% of the of your cost
now being
Pharmaceuticals that's increased by
double over the last 10% of 10 years so
you're seeing a trajectory there that we
want to have levers and control over and
so in the most recent uh contract this
is your largest state contracts with the
mcos that went into into place in
September a 5-year contract we wanted to
get some better controls over that state
spend and make sure it's medically
appropriate we know there's waste we
know that there's waste all the time in
the system you think look at anybody's
uh
uh closet or medication cabinets you see
lots of drugs that are not used that's
been money paid out and for Medicaid
beneficiaries that's wasted tax dollars
money in some cases so we call this
oftentimes poly Pharmacy the
overprescribing or uh a fragmented
Health Care System where one provider
doesn't know what the other provider is
prescribing and you get drugs prescribed
to people that interact with each other
or uh or they just don't need to be on
and so we put some controls in place on
this now we were paying in the past the
Managed Care Organization something to
do a comprehensive medication review but
they don't they're not in the lever
point to be able to control what's being
prescribed or taken or filled by a
beneficiary primarily it's the primary
care provider who has the best vantage
point and so it's lifted some of the
funds that were being paid to the mcos
out of the contract and for the next 5
years we're directing those funds to the
primary care providers having them do
something called a comprehensive
medication review that during their
office visit we'll pay them a nominal
amount but appropriate uh to do a review
not only what they're prescribing but
they're going to have data fed to them
from the manag Care organizations of all
the other drugs being prescribed by the
other providers it's not in their the
medical record of the the
beneficiary so the idea then is this is
going to then cut down on inappropriate
prescribing there's a few other
mechanisms that we have in place go
ahead yes repres so this is fascinating
um uh do you have what what is the
incentive of the primary care doctor to
make the hard decision where they look
at it and they go you're prescribed uh
medic medication x uh why would do just
as well so I'm going to move you to why
to save some
money what what is the the incentive
there and is it that would that be the
same incentive for them to look at it
and go you've been prescribed 20 each of
these and you really only need 10 you
know so so where where why would a
primary care doctor want to do the right
thing when it causes them to have a
little bit of conf work and conflict
with the patient right well I think most
primary care providers want to do the
right thing they want the right
medication at the right time for the
right patient and so we're going to pay
them now in the past they were never
paid for this they were just expected to
do this in their office visit without
any additional renumeration so we're
going to pay them for that very small
amount of money compared to when you
think about uh what pharmaceutical cost
this taxpayers there's other mechanisms
in place to get what we talking about we
have for a number of years now I think
three the last 5year contract something
called a common formulary where we have
first line medications that for any
medical condition uh are the only
medication that you can get as a patient
or beneficiary of Medicaid without
having additional scrutiny something
called a prior authorization
process a lot of criticism of the PRI
authorization process nationally but you
haven't heard so much about the Medicaid
Program you've he about it in other
areas the Medicaid Program primarily
what we're doing is making sure that
individuals have access to a medication
in every single drug class
and it is available um and we've so it's
medically appropriate but it's also in
the best interest of taxpayers because
we've looked at the total cost of each
of those of the different drug options
in each of those drug
classes and have looked at the rebates
amount what is actually financially best
for the State uh in making those
decisions while making sure it's
medically appropriate the comp um so
there are other mechanisms now that's
really driving these increasing costs
and that's new medications new
Pharmaceuticals hitting the market some
amazing technology cell and Gene
therapies we've had uh there's children
now with some rare conditions called um
spinal muscular atrophy there's sickle
cell anemia some conditions now now that
are being amazingly cured with these new
very very high cost medications and
we've had an increase I think in the
last last year we've had about 10 cases
we haven't had any Cel anemia cases on
these medications yet but we've had the
spinal muscular atrophy and other
conditions where this drug cost you know
one2 million for one dosage of the
medication so in the past those were
carved out of the Medicaid contracts and
so those were all incurred direct cost
of the
taxpayers out carved out now what we
have done is we have put them back into
to the MCO process we're sharing the
risk with them utilizing their National
expertise their their ability to uh
enact proper utilization
management and we've created a high-risk
pool though to uh that they can draw
down from for some of those highrisk
high cost medications we think we're
getting ahead of what is to be seen I
looked just looked this morning at the
National Drug pipeline expected
medications to get approved from the FDA
and it's it's vast and very high cost
and I think what our method does is
getting ahead of that to get those costs
contained in a medically appropriate
way so does the commissioner already
have that Authority or does the
legislature need to provide additional
Authority U for working with the mcos to
set some of those parameters because
we're we're we're
basically the other word here that it's
worth avoiding generally is we're
rationing care right and and does the
commissioner have a sufficient authority
to to set it up so that we can make some
make the right decisions we are under
obligations in our state plan to provide
all medically necessary care of of those
mandatory Services Pharmacy obviously is
an optional service but it's so El link
I mean pharmace pharmaceutical Services
is a huge part of just what we do in
medicine these days to treat people so
it's so linked with it I I there is some
place where we need some help um and
that is the state statute requires what
we call generics first and meaning that
we need to use generic drugs
preferentially over brand name drugs
however in the Medicaid Program based on
the discounts that are available to the
Medicaid
Program um the net cost to us is cheaper
sometimes a lower net cost to use the
brand name when you take into account
the the rebates that we receive um I'm
hoping you'll see legislation this
session to allow Medicaid to be able to
purchase drugs at um so that sounds
reasonable but are we past the Hope
stage though are you aware of any
legislation that's believe that there's
Senator gray is introducing legislation
on Thursday this week uh that will allow
the state to have the authority to uh
very good have the best rebates options
even if it's brand name because
sometimes the brand name will be cheaper
than the generic right so so I I do
think that between that what we're just
talking about legislative proposal what
Dr ballad was still uh laid out to you
that those that's just the the pharmacy
area um and you know we have other um
programs that we use to um incent the
mcos on on performance um we have a we
call a withhold program to achieve
certain quality objectives oftentimes
quality is connected to cost in terms of
um managing for certain outcomes like
you know in the news there been a lot
about lead testing you know we have in a
withhold arrangement to improve the
level of lead testing um and we have uh
also um certain measures on penalties
that we can um assess what we call a
remedy or a collect a fee if they're not
meeting contract obligations I think
we're we're trying to tighten up all the
areas that we can tighten up in that
Managed Care program that are
appropriate and and generally would be
enhancing quality not taking away from
it the other area that we talked about
at the uh commissioner's opening was
around the Coordinated Care the primary
care services so we have these
mechanisms within our
contract uh but we still have those
obligations if we're going to have a
Medicaid Program to do those state plan
programs as you say and there is
certainly a fixed cost to
that U representative noan yes the
question I have is how does this uh
overlap with the right to right to try
and experimental drugs I a lot of the
things you're talking about fall into
the category of experimental drugs which
usually weren't covered under a lot of
situations but it seems to me the the
right to try legislation has some some
cost elements to it I'm wondering how
that uh coverage Works representative
that's a very good question so in
Medicaid we do not pay for experimental
drugs right to try Federal legislation
refers to FDA studies and NIH studies
and that as a study is ongoing allows
access to that medication uh to a person
who's not enrolled in the study and it's
really on the drug manufacturers to to
work with the the person who's wanting
that medication to allow them access
it's totally separate from anything we
do in Medicaid so so it doesn't play
into the cost equation so far as the
state is concerned that's correct
sir represent
Stringham uh well thank you for I mean
this is a longer conversation that we've
had on Pharmaceuticals than we had all
in the last uh uh last two year by Anum
uh very frustrating because there's uh
so little um flexibility in what drugs
are covered there's so little
flexibility in how much we pay for at
least one drug in each class and um and
uh uh no no real ability to uh adjust
copays and so on so um uh it's not
surprising that this part of the
Medicaid spend is growing faster than uh
some of the other um other areas of the
Medicaid uh budget um you know I I know
there's at least 50 drugs that plan to
Target a a user price of at least a
million dollars out there that we may
find uh one or more patients uh in in
the State uh in the Medicaid Program um
uh would be you know may benefit from
and you know frankly Frank FR frankly I
find that kind of hard because I know
how much a million dollar
could do if we spread it around um you
know 10,000 Medicaid recipients or
others around the state uh but um uh the
way the national drug laws are written
that if it's reasonable and medically
necessary uh for the patient and you're
in the Medicaid Program you have to
provide it and there's no uh flexibility
on price on that side of things if if
that sound reasonably accurate on it it
does I think another component that's
being looked at is um medical utility as
well I think you see some states using
that
language um when they consider test like
biomarkers so that's another rising cost
nationally is biomarker testing we cover
biomarkers in New Hampshire is
particularly useful in some treatments
for Cancer Care uh but we do it on a
case-by Case basis looking at the
utility in each situ situation so that's
that's another thing that we're looking
at very closely so I think you're
referring to you know you have to have a
uh analytical validity for a new test
that it's consistent you need clinical
validity and that it tells you some
information and then you need uh uh the
kind of utility that says you can do
something you know the fact that the
weather you had a perfect weather report
if you're not going outside or doesn't
change anything doesn't there's no
reason to pay for something that doesn't
change that doesn't provide information
that provides uh uh a change in in
medical uh care going forward is that
what you're referring to there yes sir
that's exactly what I'm referring to so
and
um uh I did want to ask um so there's
lack of flexibility in a lot of the
pharmaceutical pricing uh um but some of
the other Medicaid uh uh areas um isn't
their ability to uh compress uh the
amount you pay for a service if you
think it's going to be used so much that
uh it's going to blow out the budget um
and one example might be nursing homes
uh that I know there's a you know some
kind of compression factor that goes in
much like way the federal government
does for the hospital
outpatient um uh fee schedule the
inpatient fee schedule and the physician
fee schedule when they expect to have
greater utilization they just compress
the amount they pay per per Service Unit
so thank you there's a certain amount of
that but I think the the nursing home
one will be covered in another session
but you know we pay inpatient cases on a
um diagnostic Related Group the case
rate um and so that's one way that we
control it I I do I'm hoping that I can
hit the last slide before we break here
um the last slide's the potential
changes coming yes okay so so I'm going
to give you a segue here too and that is
uh uh I don't want to ask you direct
questions about hb1 or hb2 I'll just say
that if you need some legislative
assistance with any of this please make
sure that the the governor hands us a an
hb2 item to look
at yes sir so um and then you know just
for more context on this uh this
Medicaid uh Management Area represents
12% of all the general funds the state
spends so it's a it's a big it's a big
number so and 12% of the department
budget yeah no that's 12% of the
department budget not all funds so go go
ahead I think you want to talk about 47
yes um you know if some of these
proposals are adopted I think it it U
will be a different conversation that
we'll need to have um but um you know
one obviously is the change in the the
Medicaid expansion Federal match from
90% um there's also a proposal to lower
the floor of the fmap From Below 50% to
potentially going as low as
40% um and then
um in terms of uh there's also
discussions uh about uh going to like a
block grant per capita funding um at a
state level I mean we looked at this I
think a couple legislation legislative
sessions before maybe back in 18 17 type
of time frame you know it depends on the
terms and conditions around a a block
grant kind of situation um and then
probably the biggest one you know would
in terms of the Medicaid enhancement tax
the the the uh tax that's used to
generate the mquip payment for nursing
homes um there could be there proposals
to reduce the amount of uh level of tax
where 6% is the current cap but there
are some proposals to go five or four or
three or two um and those would have a
significant impact on on the state there
there are additional there's a list of
of additional ones that are that are out
there as well um terms of the ability to
use directed payments the ability to um
have other flexibilities that we have
today that um would you know increase
the amount of General funds that would
be required to sustain the programs and
so um a lot of this is going to come up
in the continuing reconciliation act um
this coming
um March April time frame another one is
you know the amount of disproportionate
share funds that states are allotted um
if the Contin if there's not a
continuing resolution New Hampshire's um
amount of funds that we could draw would
be reduced from a little over 200
million to under a 100 million and um we
expect that probably Congress won't
adopt that but there is a risk if they
can't come to an agreement that you we
could see a significant drop there all
these things if if they were to one or
more of them would happen I think we
have to have a different discussion than
we're having today in terms of how we
and uh so our our goal is to keep you
informed along the
way let's tease that out how will you
keep us informed along the
way we we like if you read a good
article I mean I don't know how you get
your information whether it's you're
you're paying attention to
the some bulletin somewhere you're
talking to your peers so National
Medicaid directors I'm on the board of
the national Medicaid directors and um
you know through that organization and
um also the the Commissioners on uh um
and a a group of Commissioners and our
long-term Services support folks have a
group and I think that information
typically is you know we're meeting
every week to get legislative updates I
think when there's something that's
that's either of concern that we need to
bring to your attention or something
that's now baked ready for consideration
I mean I could communicate to the this
this committee and send you an an email
of that and if you feel like you want us
to come in and talk to you about it be
willing to do that too at any time you
know I I won't I won't prescribe how you
do it I just want you to know that I'm I
I appreciate your offer to keep us
informed and I I would like to be kept
inform formed because that stuff is
moving pretty quick yes um I mean last
week uh you know the when the the whole
change and just trying to find out
what's going on within 24 hours is you
know the amount of information that I
learned hour to hour and that was really
important uh to fortunately um you know
our funds reopen back up to be able to
draw but you know something like like an
issue where we're going to have a change
that's going to affect us we really to
get that information out to you I I
wouldn't want to obligate you to overc
communicating either CU I I know a lot
of it it's just Chasing Ghosts until
things start to form but um now this is
a list of uh risks which are all
negative these are these are threats do
do we see any happy risks do we see any
opportunities is there in this chaos and
opportunity for somebody to go to DC and
say you know what would be really great
is if we could get you know the the the
healthy worker um off of Medicaid for
example yeah so I know um one of the
areas that they expect there to be um
either legislation or um Federal
guidance is around the work requirement
which we're talking I think about and I
know this
session there's a there's legislation to
be um considered I think one of the
things um about that is I think you know
um that you could help with is making
sure that we um you know we spent quite
a bit of money setting up the current
work requirement that's in legislation
is to make sure that um we understand
clearly what the picture is federally
before we you know start spending money
I know that this is one of the tightest
budgets that that we'll all go through
and um you know in terms of just the
timing on the runway to do something I
think is important on that topic um so
so I've just heard rumors that somebody
has a bill to do
to come back to workers requirements
here in New Hampshire yeah I I'm I'm
expecting that that there'll be
something this session on on that just
because I think it's nationally uh very
uh discussed topic is there anything
else do we want some more flexibility on
eligibility or the kind of care provided
I mean so so I think in terms of the the
flexibilities around um um there's
regulation for example on the nursing
homes and um on the Staffing personel
requirement that's pretty new right that
that potentially could be um there could
be some relief there there could be some
additional flexibilities around How We
Do eligibility um in terms of uh um
whether all the regulations that were
were published last uh spring whether
there'll be some relief in terms of the
the timing on on that I think those will
take different actions um but
and you're you're working those with the
commissioner or you need legislative uh
legislature to be included I you know at
this point
um I think I would need to to take a
look at at which ones we might have to I
can share that I think um when it comes
to changing certain eligibilities uh
certain processes we would need that
certainly work requirements we would
need legislative um help there so I just
just want to let you know I'm from the
government and I'm here to
help I am
too not representive
Daniels thank you irrespective of what
happens at the federal government it
would seem that the one of the goals of
the department would try to raise a
person's standard to the point where
they can get off of Medicaid right and
to that to that end uh what is the
department uh doing or undertaking as a
goal to try to redu the number of people
on Medicaid so I think um return you
know one thing is to make sure that the
people who are on Medicaid are actually
eligible for Medicaid right um and that
we in terms of our eligibility
capabilities um you know there's always
room for improvement I will will say
that but you know we were able to
effectively um you know work to get our
um elig people who are not eligible for
the program um moved off of of coverage
in terms of of that and I think in terms
of making sure that we we give people um
um a good chance to provide information
and to um make sure my goal every day is
to make sure that someone who's eligible
maintains their eligibility someone who
isn't that we you know need to try to
support them either through exchange
coverage or some other option um but
that's I mean ultimately I think our
responsibility in the department is to
you know run eligibility as it is but
also other things that we do outside of
the Medicaid Program um directly or in
some of the program areas you know
helping someone get to a point where um
you know they're they're able to to
function and work and you know
transition from not being able to work
because of a health condition to being
able to to work and self-support
themselves there's you know other
Federal programs that are designed to
help people lift people up and out and I
think you know a good example of that is
our 1115 waiver that the component
regarding Community re-entry is
individuals who have the state has
invested money while they're behind bars
if you will um and um the ability to to
bring um support so that once they enter
the community all that good work to try
to uh keep them on the right track to
being able to to not have medical issues
result in a relapse of them going back
to prison as an example um so I think
there are things that we're trying to do
to you know as we should within the and
that's the benefit of having us all
under one umbrella of the leveraging up
the different opportunities to to allow
program are there any questions from the
committee do do do you do you all have
any closing remarks or additional things
to
add thank you for your time and
attention for sure this is this is
something that we've skimmed over in
previous budgets and I I I even when I
was on HHS I never really fully
understood the the depth of this program
so so I appreciate that and I think
there's still more to learn you know we
could have taken another hour with the
easy I think but um to go over all the
waivers more specifically but is is
anyone in the audience care to make any
comments ask any questions little bit of
an open Forum opportunity jump
ball okay oh yes come on up uh there's a
a mic right there at the end of this
long table and you you can you can sit
there and you can hit that button to
make it red and just bring it towards
your mouth not quite as easy as it
sounded um Carolyn virtue granite
caseman management the one thing that I
would like to say about the waivers is
that they were never in the
mcos so it wouldn't be bringing them
back it would be adding them to and um
there was a lot of
discussion around that as Henry said in
2018 and um it was not found to be a
great idea and I'm not sure it would be
um found to be a great idea now but um
you know if that's your plan it should
be fully vetted thank you there is no
plan this was a con I just want to jump
on the word plan there is no plan we
have no intention than to talk being
floated yeah okay thank you yes ma'am
thank you for your testim
and and thank you over the years for
educating me Miss virtue i' I remember
early on you were a great mentor thank
you uh any other new questions anyone
from the audience so Mr Ripple I'll end
with you when when when do we meet again
when's our next meeting uh well you
don't have one scheduled but I was going
to ask if this coming Monday the 10th at
1M would work for the remaining pre
pre-budget presentations from the
Department
it it would for me it'll give everyone a
chance to look at their calendar okay it
VP
yeah but what do you have a a short list
of topics like like I want to I want to
hit the UNH contracts at some point so
that's something I could discuss with
the Department as cover uh to cover
during their Public Health presentation
which is one that's coming up up um also
developmental Services which was
previously um delayed and elderly and
adult which was also previously delayed
and that would include a discussion of
Nursing Facility financing okay so
that's a that's a really big day or do
do we need to make those two days I
think one day would work starting at 1M
start earlier then or ask few your
questions you could start earlier if the
committee would
[Music]
prefer uh
what's 10:00 look like for people 10:00
and then we'll take a a lunch and we'll
come
back you can't can you come anytime on
on the 10th representative Daniels uh
one one o00 actually works very well for
me okay
um
so let's start it let's go ahead and
start at one I'm a little nervous
because it sounds like a pretty full
plate
well what yeah pencil Us in another date
for a fall back and I don't know if if
we've missed the window for the calendar
I I no you haven't okay so so go ahead
and pencil Us in for an overflow um and
then we can cancel it if we don't need
it okay sounds good
okay anything else thank you so much I
appreciate it I know that's a lot of
preparation and particularly I don't
think you've given this slide deck
before so this was a new build all fresh